there it is a win for the ages
a win for the ages we all remember that
day it has been 25 years since tiger
woods sunk the putt and first on the
green jacket of a masters champion now
he'll look to do it for the sixth time
when he makes his remarkable comeback at
augusta national golf club and
remarkable is a word there woods is
scheduled to tee off tomorrow just 14
months 14 months after a devastating car
accident when he nearly lost his leg so
this is his first major event since then
jim axelrod was at tigers news
conference yesterday in augusta georgia
jim i'm thinking this master's
tournament just got a little more
interesting to a whole lot of people
oh my we saw some vintage tiger woods on
display when he met with us here in
augusta yesterday this is not a guy who
does just happy to be here when he was
asked if he thought he could win not
just did he think he could play but did
he think he could win he answered very
simply but very confidently i do and as
anyone knows who's watched tiger woods
handle challenge after challenge over
the course of his career there is hardly
ever any upside in betting against him
well as of right now i feel like i am
going to play
they're the words the sports world was
waiting for i don't show up to event
unless i think i can win it his news
conference declaration capped days of a
building will he or won't he frenzy the
enormous crowds following tiger woods
practice round monday impressed u.s open
champ john rahm who was out on the
course at the same time
i've never seen a mask this big even in
a sunday in contention on those two
holes
his accident 14 months ago in southern
california almost cost woods his right
leg and left him unsure if he would ever
walk properly again let alone play
augusta national which is known for its
hilly terrain to say that i was going to
be here playing
and talking to you guys again
[Music]
would have been very unlikely but here
he is his game sharp the only questions
are about his stamina i don't
have any qualms about what i can do
physically from a golf standpoint it's
now
walking is a hard part you know this is
normally not a
easy walk to begin with tiger did play
in a father-son tournament in december
finishing second with his son charlie
but he rode in a cart then
this is something entirely different the
masters and a chance to write another
chapter of golf history no one thought
possible
if you hadn't been able to go
would you be satisfied with your career
here
and your career in general my pt's
with my surgeons they all said that i
could i could do this again
now it's up to me to endure the pain and
and all that but
i felt like i could still do this and i
don't know how many more years i can do
this but if you couldn't have would have
you been satisfied yes i would have i
think i think 82 is a pretty good number
and 15 is not too bad either
tiger was referring of course to his 82
wins on tour in his 15 major
championships now he will play nine more
practice holes today and if all feels
right he will put a t in the ground
tomorrow morning just after 10 30 a.m
eastern time in the 86th playing of the
masters tony
boy jim you're right uh tiger is not a
uh just happy to be here kind of press
conference guy that was a great report
uh and you're lucky to be down there i'm
envious thank you very much how about
this and i love tiger's confidence too
yes yes i think i can win i don't enter
events i don't think i can win i think i
think even his competition is rooting
for him because look at what he's done
for the sport of golf yeah it's one
thing to root for him but does the
competition fear him like they used to
i'm not sure they do because he isn't
tiger of old to the young guns he's just
an old tiger uh yeah but you know what
he won the u.s open with a torn acl and
there's fractures in his legs so he's
used to painting i think they still fear
him really yup he's still freaking tiger
woods he walks out on that course with a
confidence that he has he still has
something yeah he is still freaking out
one big tee off and a pop of that ball
yeah yeah yeah yeah we all have our eyes
on tiger that's